A computação quântica entrou na era da utilidade
o que significa que podemos começar a usar computadores quânticos para resolver
problemas do mundo real, incluindo alguns que são muito difíceis
para computadores clássicos
um tema comum na era atual
é que um problema é resolvido
pela primeira vez em um computador quântico
e depois as pessoas encontram uma maneira de fazê-lo em um computador clássico
esse ciclo de computação clássica
e quântica se impulsionando mutuamente até seus
limites provavelmente vai continuar
por alguns anos existem classes de problemas onde a computação quântica
pode ter uma vantagem comprovável
sobre a computação clássica
dado o progresso em áreas como
a redução de erros e o número de qubits disponíveis
existem também áreas de aplicação inteiras
onde a computação quântica
pode ser útil em um futuro relativamente próximo
uma dessas áreas é o aprendizado de máquina quântico ou QML
o aprendizado de máquina quântico se refere a
aplicação da computação quântica a qualquer tipo de processo de aprendizado
de máquina existem é claro
muitos tipos de aprendizado de máquina
dois tipos de interesse particular são
o aprendizado supervisionado no qual você
treina um algoritmo usando um conjunto de dados rotulado
e o aprendizado não supervisionado no qual
o algoritmo trabalha a partir de amostras não rotuladas
e tenta aprender sobre a distribuição
ou a função que a gera
um algoritmo não supervisionado pode
por exemplo aprender como gerar novas amostras
da mesma distribuição ou como
agrupar as amostras em grupos com características semelhantes
tanto o aprendizado supervisionado quanto o não supervisionado frequentemente envolvem
a incorporação de dados em espaços de dimensões mais altas
e a manipulação de dados em espaços de dimensões mais altas
deve nos fazer pensar em computação quântica
deixa eu explicar imagine tentar resolver o problema de
classificar um ponto de dados do plano
como um círculo ou uma cruz dado os dados de treinamento rotulados aqui
às vezes os dados podem ser claramente separados por uma linha
ou plano em dimensões baixas
como mostrado aqui e classificar esses pontos de dados de acordo
com os que estão acima da linha
e abaixo da linha deve ser
tranquilo mas olhe para essa distribuição
claramente não há nenhuma linha visível que separe os pontos de dados
porém para esses dados poderíamos imaginar algum
mapeamento de duas dimensões para três dimensões
de forma que após aplicar o mapeamento nossos dados ficam
assim e há claramente um plano que separa as duas
classes que podemos usar
para classificação se esse tratamento parece um pouco simplista
você está certo não podemos simplesmente colocar os pontos de dados que queremos
mais acima sem justificativa
tem que haver um mapeamento
a partir da distribuição 2D que efetivamente separa
nossos pontos de dados para que possamos
usar o mapeamento para classificar novos pontos de dados
isso será discutido mais na lição que apresenta uma visão geral de
aprendizado de máquina mas basta dizer
que o problema pode ser visto
como tentar muitos mapeamentos diferentes nesse espaço dimensional mais alto
para ver quais mapeamentos produzem a melhor
separação de pontos de dados de classes diferentes
essa manipulação de dados em dimensões mais altas
é uma área onde a computação quântica
pode ter um grande impacto para entender por quê
vamos voltar às diferenças entre computação clássica
e quântica assim como
os computadores clássicos usam bits de informação
os computadores quânticos usam qubits
mas para um dado número de bits digamos quatro
um computador clássico pode assumir qualquer um dos
dois elevado a quatro ou dezesseis estados possíveis
um computador quântico também pode acessar dezesseis estados possíveis
mas ele pode existir em uma superposição de todos os
dezesseis estados simultaneamente
e operações podem ser realizadas em toda essa superposição
para quatro qubits isso pode não parecer
uma grande coisa mas imagine o que poderia ser feito com
um computador quântico em dois elevado a vinte ou
dois elevado a cento e vinte e sete
estados simultaneamente existem muitas outras diferenças
entre computação clássica e quântica que vão
todas desempenhar um papel nesse assunto
os estados quânticos têm amplitudes de probabilidade complexas
as manipulações de sistemas quânticos são realizadas com
operadores unitários e os computadores quânticos estão sujeitos a
tipos diferentes de ruído do que os computadores clássicos
essas diferenças vão aparecer
ao longo do seu trabalho de aprendizado de máquina quântico em áreas
como codificação de dados mapeamento de características e mitigação de erros
em alguns casos essas diferenças entre computação clássica
e quântica nos permitem projetar
algoritmos totalmente novos agora isso foi uma visão geral muito breve
da união de dois campos imensamente complexos
mas esperamos que duas coisas estejam claras
o aprendizado de máquina frequentemente resolve problemas
manipulando dados em dimensões muito altas
e em segundo lugar os computadores quânticos são bem adequados
para manipular dados em dimensões altas
e fazem isso de forma diferente dos sistemas clássicos
isso deve dar a você uma noção
de por que o aprendizado de máquina é um campo promissor
para a aplicação da computação quântica útil